Geh deinen Weg,
sag mir, woher du kommst und
wohin du gehst.
Wo ist dein Weg?
Geh deinen Weg,
sag mir, woher du kommst und
wohin du gehst.
Was ist dein Ziel?
Du bist endlich da,
es ist schön, dich zu sehen.
Du hast dich entschieden,
neue Wege zu gehen.
Herzlich willkommen,
deine Reise hat begonnen,
hast 'ne neue Chance,
neue Heimat gewonnen.
Schritt für Schritt
entdeckst du dein neues Leben -
gehst Schritt für Schritt
neuen Freunden entgegen.
Wohin die Wege dich führen,
bleibt ein Geheimnis,
doch du wirst es schon schaffen,
auch wenn es nicht immer leicht ist.
Geh deinen Weg,
sag mir, woher du kommst und
wohin du gehst.
Wo ist dein Weg?
Geh deinen Weg,
sag mir, woher du kommst und
wohin du gehst.
Was ist dein Ziel?
Du willst etwas bewegen,
lernen, lachen und leben,
fährst auf deinem Fahrrad
durch Sonne und Regen.
Es gibt so viel zu erleben,
zu nehmen und geben,
neue Abenteuer als
Geschenk anzunehmen.
Hör auf dein Herz,
Fremde werden Freunde,
gemeinsame Ziele,
gemeinsame Träume.
Geh deinen Weg,
die Reise macht dich klüger.
Liegen Steine im Weg,
spring einfach drüber.
Geh deinen Weg,
sag mir, woher du kommst und
wohin du gehst.
Wo ist dein Weg?
Geh deinen Weg,
sag mir, woher du kommst und
wohin du gehst.
Wo ist dein Weg?
Geh deinen Weg,
sag mir, woher du kommst und
wohin du gehst.
Was ist dein Ziel?